hey everybody this is Jimmy with bright
insight get ready to be blown away guys
because today I'm going to discuss with
you the 100 ton stone boxes found within
the Serie pium at Saqqara Egypt now
these are completely unexplainable even
the minister of antiquity for Egypt has
stated on MSNBC and CNN that they quote
do not know how these were made or how
they got there now they are underground
and they're found within a tunnel system
of 33 nooks and within these nooks there
are 27 boxes and each weighs
approximately 100 tons 70 tons for the
box and 30 tons for the solid lid and
they are made out of either granite or
basalt now each lid was cut from the
exact same piece of stone as the box
itself and the precision of the way
these were engineered is completely
amazing we're talking perfect 90-degree
angles and we're also talking about
being machine cut to within to ten
thousandths of an inch
think of it that for a moment now these
were found in 1850 they're like I said
they're completely unexplainable there
are some thoughts that maybe they were
used as tombs for bulls and there's this
whole elaborate story about that but
they were never found with any one or
anything within them at all in fact all
but one were found with the stones uh
covers lids open and the one that was
sealed shut
was actually blasted using gunpowder
which is very unfortunate but what's
interesting about this is that even
though it was sealed shut when they
blasted it open they found nothing
now there's also evidence that the
inscriptions that you can see here on
the outside of the lids we're done after
the boxes were made so it's widely
believed that these boxes were were
constructed before the dynastic
Egyptians and that perhaps the dynastic
Egyptians went in there carve different
uh you know as you can see different
writings and shapes and of animals on
them which by the way does not compare
at all to the precision of the boxes
themselves in fact it looks like the
actual inscriptions were done very
roughly in anything that's you know
analyzed up close you can see it for
yourself
now it's important for me to mention
that I've been inspired and first
learned of these through Brien Foerster
who has a YouTube channel and he also
has a website called hidden em Couture's
com I highly recommend you look into him
because this guy is absolutely brilliant
and what he's doing is just phenomenal
because this is opening a whole
Pandora's box for showing that yes there
is lost ancient high technology that was
utilized to construct these boxes now
something that's worth mentioning that
is completely unexplainable as well is
the fact that these boxes are located
within their own little nooks and one of
these nooks where the box is found in
based on the dimensions of the box we're
talking 15 feet long 10 feet tall
absolutely huge could not have fit
around the corner of one of these
tunnels and into the Nook where it's
placed now they have no idea how it got
there could not have fit and again these
are underground so what was really
placed there before the you know it was
sealed like what it's unexplainable how
did they get there we don't know I could
throw out some ideas but that's for
another video in itself what's important
to understand here is even if you wanted
to believe the common Egyptian you know
thesis which is that okay they had
slaves do everything even if these
things were a fraction of the way to
just put this in perspective 100 tons is
200,000 pounds how you could get enough
hands of people around these boxes to
physically carry them and place them
where they're at how could you even roll
them I mean we're talking 200,000 pounds
seriously guys think about that it's it
is believed and hypothesize that perhaps
these were used for some sort of
electricity or power generating I mean
look it's obviously with a technology
that we don't know or understand today
but these things clearly have purpose
they were clearly in my opinion
industrial up you know in some way
because they're clearly placed it's easy
for someone to think that maybe this was
the tomb but why is it that they were
empty and why go to such enormous extent
to create something so big so heavy and
with in such amazing precision because
like I said within 2 10 thousandths of
an inch being flat Wow so when you look
at all this you know
there's clear evidence that this was
done with some sort of capability or
technology that we
half today or that was on par of which
we do have today and what makes us so
interesting is that this was done
thousands of years ago and we have no
idea how they were done anyways guys
look at the pictures decide for yourself
it's clear evidence that what we have
been taught and what we think of ancient
history is far from the truth
anyways I'm Jimmy this is bright insight
if you like what I have to say like and
subscribe I have many other videos for
you to enjoy and many more coming be
blessed all